want to turn to my next guest who knows
all about the cauldron of
performing in philadelphia uh and then
doing so
uh with the eyes um
looking at him with a ton of expectation
uh
we won a super bowl with the
philadelphia eagles beating tom brady
and he won a super bowl with his current
team in his first time around with them
beating
peyton manning he's the only human being
to defeat either one of those guys both
of those guys in a super bowl
his name is malcolm jenkins how are you
malcolm
doing well how you been brother i am
doing better always for
for talking to you okay um i
i know this is not your current team but
i'm i'm i'm wondering what you do
think of if i don't you don't mind me
just throwing you in right now as part
of the paparazzi
um and what you think of what is going
on with your former team in in
philadelphia do you have any thoughts on
that subject malcolm jenkins if so what
are they
well you know i'm gonna be honest i
hadn't really paid
um a ton of attention to it you know i i
was really just
you know looking around the league to
look at you know with all the coaching
vacancies you know
how they want to handle you know black
coaches and what opportunities are going
to come
um but but i do know that whoever
you know was going to take over that job
in philly
was inheriting um you know some work
and i think jeffrey laurie made some
some comments earlier this offseason
that
that hinted or was really direct about
you know they're going into a rebuilding
phase and you know and i know as players
on a team
and as a fan base you never really want
to hear that
um because it it it sometimes
kind of muddies up what the priorities
are but um
look you know they got a situation where
obviously
they're all that went down with carson
wentz this year a lot of money vetted
uh invested into them um and then you
had jalen hurts come in and and really
take command of this the offense
ignited a little bit of juice into the
team um and that's not the first time
that that's happened
you know from a backup quarterback
obviously right in philly
and so it's it's it's one of those
things that like something
something has to change you know whether
you put that on this on the coaching
staff or you put that
onus on the players that are that are
there
um but i mean you know there's obviously
going to be a lot of work to be done
there but they've got they've got
great leadership they've got um players
you know in that locker room that are a
private group
and what you hope to see is that
at least from a fan right i'm i'm i even
call myself an eagles fan
um you just hope that the
competitiveness
that the culture and the
uh kind of the ethos of what that team
stands for at least stays in place
so again you know as a fan of the eagles
you do
however have quite a unique perspective
and one more
follow-up on this is there
an issue with wence in that locker room
we keep on hearing about it you were
there when there was a
a magazine article locally that came out
so there was a big problem with whence
and players in that locker room
is there an issue is there any there
there about carson wentz
that you can share with us malcolm well
i think
you know as a teammate in front of
carson's i
i think that you know it always starts
right with performance
and he hadn't performed up to uh i think
the expectations that everybody's had
for him and and i don't think he would
say he's
played up to his own expectations um but
some of the other issues that i felt you
know when i was in the locker room
was just that you know that there was
just too much
um leeway um and it didn't make him a
better player
i don't think they did him any favors by
you know trying to
kind of protect his ego or trying to
um you know just just really protect him
as a player as opposed to
it keeping it just like every other
player is like keeping it
performance-based
and and really being you know real about
what he needed to improve on but also
adjusting
to to put him in places that you know
that that are
that can make him successful and i think
you know that's a little bit on coaching
style that's also
some bonus on the player like every
player go should go into every offseason
evaluating what they did well they
didn't do well and you look to see
improvement year after year
um but if if that's not the case and you
don't see it and there are no changes
and it's not being addressed then i know
like as a player
you almost feel like you know what are
we doing you know you're
to do the same thing over and over again
i'm expecting different results is
insanity
and and unfortunately i think that a
little bit of that
has you know taken place over the last
few years
and obviously you know this offseason
showed that
something had to change in a major way
uh and carson's still there
and and so he's still regardless of who
they bring in for
you know to coach him and getting better
he's still going to have to improve as a
player
in order for that team to have success
malcolm jenkins here on the rich eisen
show
let's talk about the hiring round uh
david cully
being introduced by the texans right now
um
he is uh a a coach of color
the jets hiring the first muslim uh to
be a head coach
in the nfl and then the rest are
um white men what do you think of the
current round of
hiring in the nfl malcolm jenkins
uh i think it's uh it's to me it's been
on par with the status quo you know
every time
we bring up these conversations and and
and and
you know talk about how many qualified
african-american coaches that there are
out there to get opportunities they just
never seem to do that you know and um
you know and it's unfortunate and you
see uh how many coaches that are white
that get those jobs you know with little
uh
you know um with very little experience
with
very little credentials uh oftentimes
coming from
team or having a resume that isn't
impressive at all
um you know it's it's one of those
things where
as even as a player in this league who's
trying to be vocal on it and
and give my perspective on some of the
coaches that have helped myself like
aaron glenn who just got a d coordinator
job you know in in
um in detroit
i i think he'd be a head coach in this
league deuce bailey somebody i've talked
about i think should be a head coach
you know the enemy somebody we've been
waiting to get an opportunity
and i think um
you know it's it's it's really
frustrating um when you see how these
the situations play out
um it just doesn't really seem like
there's a concerted effort to to
actually go with the most qualified
uh folks but more so with what who
people are comfortable with or
you know kind of this this good old boys
club that that is really hard to
penetrate and get into
so what's the answer you know what i'm
saying so what would you say
um if you could um you know
have the commissioner's ear uh because
clearly it is something that he he wants
to address
um yeah so what would you suggest
malcolm jenkins to try and and change
what clearly uh needs to be changed
well like anything right when you want
to change the outcome
or change the landscape of an
organization
you have to and you want especially when
it comes to diversity right you want
diversity within your organization and
that to be a priority well then you have
to
have a diverse group of decision makers
and unfortunately when you look at
the ownership in the decision makers
around our league
there's very little any diversity
and so we're expecting people who
don't have a diver you know who are not
in a diverse you know group we're
expecting decision makers that don't
have different perspectives
uh to suddenly change their minds and
hearts
um and and you know do something that's
been out of character for them for
however many long you know
how many years they've owned these teams
and so to me i think if we want to be
serious about having black coaches and
more black gm
uh and things of that nature i think
we're gonna have to have a serious
conversation about
diversifying what ownership looks like
malcolm jenkins here uh on the rich
eisen show
i'm wondering uh can you give voice to
what you and other veteran players in
the nfl
are thinking when you're seeing desean
watson um
say he wants to be traded year after
signing a big long deal
and the only thing you can equate this
to is what an nba
elite player attempts to do and get an
exit visa from a team
um and a city that he's connected to i
mean obviously harden would
i is the is the uh equivalent one would
say in terms of a player and status
elite status for desean watson clearly
they're two different
uh people but i'm wondering if you can
give voice to what you and
many other players of your uh caliber
and uh experience think about what's
going on with desean watson
in houston malcolm yeah i mean you know
contrary to belief like
some guys aren't necessarily motivated
simply by money
and and i think um
whenever you see a player of his caliber
you know of his character as well like
he's not a guy
who's got a history of being uh
you know a problem you know child in the
locker room or a guy who just
can't get along he's always been praised
as a leader and somebody who's
he's kind of stepped out in front and
when they
are really vocal about wanting to leave
a place then it's usually
you know something that you can't repair
and it's and it's beyond
working it out and i think sometimes
players have to do what's best for them
to be
in a situation where obviously they can
they want to you know
make the money but guys want to be able
to win and be happy
uh where they are you want to enjoy the
work you do
um because it's a violent sport we put
our bodies on a line and it's like when
you're in a miserable situation
on top of that um it you know it doesn't
make for good
good ball or a good career so i think
you see him doing what he needs to do to
get out of a situation that
wasn't the best for him let's talk a
couple things about your own house
malcolm jenkins do you believe
um you have played uh your last game
with drew brees do you think drew
is uh going to retire
you know i i'm i can't speculate on it
or really i can't confirm it or anything
like that but
you know what i what i have seen
and um and i can understand is that you
know drew's
his body is it's getting tougher and
tougher for him to finish these seasons
right when you get older as a player in
this league
the you really just are here for sunday
it's not the off season it's not the
training it's not practice
you are here to compete on sundays
because that's what we love to do as
players
and when you get hurt and you're in the
training room as much as he's been
um you know that's not why we're here
you know to rehab and and and go through
all those things but you're not playing
and he's missed significant time in the
last two seasons
uh his kids are getting older and i know
that's important to him spending time
with his family
um you know but as a competitor when
you're elite
is like as he's been for so long um
and to be so close with the teams that
we've had
to getting back to the super bowl and
getting an opportunity to compete for a
championship
i think that that weighs very heavily as
well so it's a it's a tough decision
i think you know we know it he's close
you know whether it's
uh this offseason or the next
uh you know he's kind of at the end of
that rope but
he's still you know very much a
competitor and knows he can compete in
his league
it's just you know he's gonna have to
make the decision you know to weigh all
the options what's
what's the most important thing for him
and his life at this moment
um and that's always that's a good
decision for him to be able to make
most of us won't won't leave this league
in our own terms
right and uh seems like he will what
about you uh
14th overall pick of the 2009 draft 13
season you can get 14 seasons
um you play this year how long how much
longer do you want to
keep doing it this this this next season
will be 13.
okay for me all right and uh you know
and i i set a goal for myself for long
long ago i want to play 10 years in this
league
and then after that you know i was going
to take it year to year based off
my my body uh you know
what my financial situations looking
like um and just like as a competitor
i feel like i accomplished you know
everything and and
you know even for me i i the thing that
has kept me going is that i've been
healthy for so long
and i haven't had to you know spend a
lot of time in the training room i've
been able to stick to doing what i love
doing that's playing on sundays
um and i'm on a really good team that's
got a lot of really good potential a
great organization
a good culture i'm having fun um so i
don't know
you know how long i'll continue to do it
it's really year to year for me
um at least i definitely know i'll be
here this season and i know you have
far more interests outside of the world
of football i do want to get an update
on that in a second
uh but first front load super bowl 55.
you played against both of these guys
one of them three times this year
um and uh how do you how do you
with your keen championship eye see
super bowl 55 going malcolm jenkins
yeah i think to me the the most
interesting storyline
is gonna be the bucks defense um
because i think you know brady as much
as they
weapons they have on offense with tom
brady and all those guys
um i still think the most
uh the the the
the best dynamic of that team is their
defense and even in the game we played
them that third time
it was a defensive battle and their
defense really outplayed ours they took
the ball away
you know forget how many times um but
we're very very stingy
in a defensive battle and that was the
difference in the game
um and they've been getting better and
better you know each week those
linebackers
are making tacos they're covering them
they're forcing
turnovers you got both those safeties i
knew were banged up but i was really
really impressed with
uh rookie winfield all year he looks
just like his dad out there
i have corners that i can match up so
and if you look at the match up with
them last time
that was really the where the game
kind of was lost was the ability to
handle
uh the chief's offense especially tariq
hill so i'm interested to see
what uh the defensive scheme is going to
be and how they handle
you know the explosiveness of uh the
chief's offense and
because i think tom brady and their
offense is going to do what they're do
and the chiefs are going to do what they
do on offense but i think it's going to
come down to
if the bucks can can continue to play
uh defense at a high level against the
best offense in the league
how's your production company uh black
boys uh
which was released in 2020 and can be
seen right here
on peacock available to stream for free
on peacock
right now um is is part of your
production company what's going on with
that
for you yeah so you know that that has
uh qualified to to be nominated
for uh and i said i'm definitely
hoping for that but i'm really you know
the offseason is here
you know diving really back into uh to
those projects
uh we got a couple that we want to make
i want to make black girls for sure
um and so it's just prioritizing
projects but that has been something
that i
really enjoy doing is being a
storyteller
and and and giving people
um you know black stories that we
haven't heard before
in ways that we can digest them it's
really hard you know
you and you you're familiar with how how
i've used my platform kind of in the
sports world
to to talk about these issues but
it it's hard to have sometimes it's hard
to effectively communicate
in this space because we want to be
talking about sports
um and you know there's friction there
but
through film and documentaries it just
seems to knock down some of those
barriers and walls and creates a little
bit more understanding
um and so i found i found it you know to
be
a more effective way to communicate at
least for me
and so i'm really enjoying um diving
into
creating more stories and more content
um to the production company well as you
know my platform is yours whenever you
want to promote anything you're doing
malcolm you know that and i'm i'm i'm
pleased to say it and
anytime seriously very much i appreciate
you
of course uh before i let you go you
surprised urban meyer's coaching in the
nfl what do you think
i'm i am you know um
i i am you know when you look at you
know his time in florida
and and he had some health issues and
left their
time at ohio state uh really you know
had a lot of success with the program
but then had to step away from it
uh so to make the jump to now the nfl
um you know it is an interesting one
and i think everybody has kind of their
eyes on to see what
what kind of culture he's going to bring
in as a
you know as a long-time college coach
but now
a rookie head coach uh in the nfl so
um it's interesting but you know i'm i'm
happy for him
um you know i think we'll
we'll look to see when you said his time
at ohio state what school is that
because i'm
i i i don't know what school that is
because
it's it's the team that your team hadn't
been able to be
no no i'm just confused because
i'm confused because normal oh i'm sorry
it's the same as the ohio state
it's just i thought well well well
you know i'm confused we've got a long
history so for
all your listeners you're right i i
i i didn't do it properly the ohio state
but i was really comfortable talking to
my old friend rich here and
you of all people know it's the ohio
state yes i do
i do but you guys dodged us this year no
no i know
blamed it on blame oh my god don't
go full herb street on me malcolm don't
do that
oh don't do that that was disappointing
i was i was disappointed
oh my gosh don't forget though when you
said the ohio state who
where where the goat went to school
right let's not forget that
correct what did you say at the top of
this i was the only
one oh my gosh
malcolm i always appreciate chatting
with you uh thanks for coming on and
always
spitting truth i really appreciate our
chats every time we have them thank you
good to talk to you all right back at
you that's malcolm jenkins at malcolm
jenkins on twitter at malcolm jenkins27
on instagram and you can once again
stream now for free
right here on this peacock app his uh
his documentary black boys which
can you imagine he wins an oscar is that
it's nominated for an oscar let's go
that'd be awesome let's go that would be
terrific hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here